so many dudes are like how do I get the
girl that I'm with to be like Layla in
business and want to be an entrepreneur
it's just like saying like how do I make
my wife a really good opera singer
unless she really likes opera singing
like she's probably not going to be
really good at it or really into it I'm
at Layla and on our first date I pitched
her on working for me I liked her
business mind and I was like I don't
even know you that well romantically but
I would hire you if that's your thing
then like you're gonna have to find
other areas of common interest now for
me the reason I did marry Layla is
because she was one of the few girls
that I enjoyed talking to because she
wanted to talk about stuff I want to
talk about which is business and so
that's how it worked for us but it
doesn't have to work that way for you